uh this one's for you this one's for be
your third eye right now like she's here
whoa you're really letting me
in
wow
how beautiful I'm seeing you so deeply
wow and very starcy as well
very grandmother
and like ancient witch she just got me
she just got white hair
she's just got white hair she's looking
at you smiling like I like Grandma
because they exist they call them
cougars yeah she just got white hair and
looking at you with a smile all the
things that you feel right now is is a
home concept of your own mind it's what
you want it to be it's not what happens
it's not what it is it's not the the
wonderful Enlightenment that you have in
your oh my God
oh my God they're really letting me in
no
no it's what you wish it would be it's
wishful thinking you're like I want it
to be so great and it becomes great
that's how religion works yeah like I
love that's the part that I love about
church yo
when [__] scream sing and shout
that [__] is hockey lit
is lit but then you got the music you
got the emotion of what you feel of your
problem of what you want your problems
to become you want to be free and that's
what helps you feel some [__] oh my God
that was so Divine not really
um
in this case
is all the same [__] but acapella her
not talking I'm good oh my God you're
really letting me in that was a great
sentence to hear
or say when I lost my virginity that is
that is 10 out of 10. oh my God you're
really letting me in it's like you know
oh my God sorry go ahead it's like you
you're doing breathing exercises and
breathing exercises can actually lead
you to something else you know I mean
like whatever you do for example yoga
whatever some people can cry some people
can even achieve orgasm but that you
also have to work it's not just the
breathing or the person is what you put
emotionally in in your head into that
thing and now you link it the other
thing that's how uh actors in actors are
able to cry
it's not so much that there's something
really tragically happening but there
are morphing this thing uh and they're
modeling this thing
and their whole way of thinking that
makes them cry method acting that's what
it is
you know you make it look real or you
link it to real events or what you
wanted to be and then you're able to cry
it's something that some people are
better to do than others you know I mean
you can make it believable that's what
it is
it's just not it's a I was about to say
it's not acting but [__] it is you just
don't know it is
stop all right I'll tell you this one's
for you oh my God the crystals are
really working they're magic and the
only magic crystals is crack
okay crystal meth derivative
okay stop that's the only rocks that are
[__] magical stop in the best way you
know like uh
I just totally left this planet Through
Your Eyes no you didn't you were my you
were you were talking in a microphone
you didn't leave everybody saw you you
live now oh my day but her spirit was
gone no it was not if the spirit will my
[__] what's wrong why does this one get
to you no it's just that looking at
someone in the eyes oh my spirit is
leaving oh no my girl
I've seen some [__] really
leave and didn't look like that but
anyways I digress carry on the same way
there's some way someone can really just
think that you want a relationship with
them it's just a wishful thinking of
them wanting a relationship but the way
you looked at me what
what but the way you looked at me and
it's just it was just so Divine that I'm
pretty sure you wanted a relationship
you're crazy
all right the same crazy
I didn't other no words I didn't gas
like you I didn't make you think yo we
should you know maybe think about nah
nah
so when you are twerking when you're
shimmying you are literally releasing
trauma leading releasing store to move
I didn't watch this clip but it's better
than I remember
oh
wow yo next week they about to hit you
with like yo when you're gang banging
you're essentially releasing
generational trauma through bullets wow
every rock is good
you did so good this video is brought to
you by surf shark no matter where I'm at
all right whether it's uh in my house or
in my Airbnb one on my way or in
Antarctica
or or even when I'm taking a [__] I need
to have access to all my programs hey
does it allow me for that because it's
restricted because of the area that I'm
in
yeah and for that I need a system that
allows me to change my location
and that's called a VPN changer yes in a
wonderful VPN that I'm using is surf
shark and it allows you to just change
the location of where you are and you
can watch everything that you want no
matter where you're at right now with
third shot you can just use promo code
Abba and preach and you're gonna be able
to have three months extra free
I know crazy get on it you did so but
the selection my guy it's almost like
you were divine and really could
yeah and it and really connected you
know and you're really like you really
like went into what you connected into
what I hate the most and you make the
most out of it and nah because I know
that you're building up a lot of anger
inside of me and I want to give you an
Avenue to release that to find a better
place a Nirvana for yourself oh my God
let go release the chakras allow that
energy to exhume itself from your body
so you can feel a natural pure Key State
these [__] they these whoa chill out
with the massages
hey let me cook hey you are you cooking
your own career
them [__]
ate some [__] uh some food some
Indian food once in their life and then
shut the [__] up about it oh my God oh
my God this Curry open my chakras it's
like it's like you girls that listen yo
you learn the word sapiosexual and you
haven't shut the [__] up about that [__]
ever since shut up
oh my God my chakras are just like so
much open right now it's not your
suckers are not open you just ate some
fish pakora calm down shaking is such a
primal practice of releasing trauma and
somatic blockages and emotions through
her body especially her hips her hips
now we know is where we store emotions
so when you are twerking absolutely yes
Queen booty butt booty butt booty butt
cheeks booty butt booty butt booty butt
cheeks
booty and then you're releasing all that
just shut the [__] up if you don't shut
up
amen
[Applause]
hey I'm not gonna laugh I'm gonna be
good all right if I'm on a date with a
girl she told me that you know spiritual
at least twerking I'm like listen I got
a lot of trouble I need to let girl so
if you try to help I got you yo my girl
can I release some shocker in your butt
come
hey man I'ma release some trauma in your
butt yeah I like women like this I don't
mind yep I like women like when you're
bending your knees you're crouching on
the floor you're connecting to Earth
you're connecting to the womb you're
restoring your energy
yo yo I wish I could take this clip take
a time machine and go see some slicks
and be like hey I see you on your knees
there
you're connected connected to the ground
booty back booty bad booty back cheeks
booty butt hey that [__] connected Ah
that's the next thing I'm gonna say
Oh that girl connected that's the new
album free slaying right now yo that
girl is connected she is
connecting because you know what I mean
and that's why it's not even just an
African dance but in Middle Eastern
hands in Latin American dance salsa
dance bachata every single dance form
has some form of hip movement to it this
is also why zebras that's not because
we're connected
no it's because it's it's very difficult
to dance without your hips no no it
looks unnatural well it looks
I See You Someday through two days about
the hips they look broken it's literally
the center of your body it's like trying
to not use your cord you're just not
gonna be dancing well
she's like no no it's spirituality
spirituality
Jesus Christ when you're running away
from a lion and they're about to get
eaten and they make it into the nick of
time they shake their bodies off release
the trauma and they come back to
homeostasis so I started to realize that
as I was doing this I was healing myself
through all of these generations of
collective trauma that night
God let the lady talk
so Miss Davis what do you want to talk
about today here with your psychologist
booty bad booty bad booty butt cheeks
Sarah I just want you to open up to me
I'm your boyfriend talk to me booty bad
booty bad booty butt cheeks every time
you open up Sarah's diary it's just
pictures are hard twerking
all right
um it's just that
oh no man there's a lot of things that
happened in my life and uh
you wrote that serious
I might even do it bro so it was just a
lot of trauma did you try twerking
watching oh I will say in her defense I
do think Danzig does you a lot of good
mentally spiritually and physical okay
but I don't think that everybody that's
working is just like highly spiritual
I'm sorry I'm not having that [__] sorry
about that yes you could be like I love
going to Brazil but when I hear
um
that's not very spiritual okay calm down
and I understand what you're saying that
there's some African dance out there
that is like twerking is taken from
whatever I understand not everything
shaking is working not everything that
Glitter is gold not everything's shaking
is bacon you understand what I'm saying
no me neither truly is a spiritual
practice and now I share it as much as I
can I told you I like this kind of way
yeah because yeah sharing is Sharon is
caring yep share it with me
days
she ain't wifeable but she [__]
anything else you like to say no no
lovely young no no no no no no I notice
of all these women who talk goofy like
this it's young women and I think I
suspect much like astrology or people
become very obsessed with these things
just a way to like make sense of the
world and give you a sense of comfort by
being connected to something bigger you
know for some men I noticed a lot of
young men are very susceptible to uh
conspiracies and different things like
that that are very crazy and out of this
world like lizard men and [__] and then
for ladies it's
twerking is spiritual or I'm looking
into your eyes and I can see the
universe
and the thing is if you've met people
who are truly spiritual they never sound
this uh self-absorbed in terms of their
powers and they never sound like they
have this much ego right now when I hear
some of these people talk it almost
looks like they can't see themselves or
how anyone else perceives them which is
like how are you this spiritual but it
seems like you're just seeing everything
in the first person
you know what I'm saying so I'm not
against people being spiritual or
finding that sense of deeper meaning in
life I just think a lot of the
representation that you see online is
oftentimes from people who seem very
shallow in their journey and seem like
they're at the beginning but want to
pretend they're masters of it
um but you know beyond that I encourage
all of you guys to start twerking I
think it's a beautiful practice and if
you'd like to share that
those videos that you guys can take and
send it in and we will judge your
spiritual practice
[Music]
where we connect
with our Spirituals
I will ask you
my people to get up
and sing with me that wonderful gospel
we have in order to connect
with the one and only God
shake your ass
show me what you working with
[Applause]
[Music]
watch yourself yeah show me what to
working with [__] yeah
yes shake what the Lord did
hey
[Music]